Trascrizione: Sarah Elhay
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Con ogni probabilità,
oggi ho mangiato più o meno
un grammo e mezzo di insetti.
In realtà l'abbiamo fatto tutti:
solo che, come me,
voi non ve ne siete accorti.
A meno che non abbiate inghiottito,
non so, una mosca, o un calabrone,
mentre venivate qui in bicicletta.
Nel nostro quotidiano, infatti,
mangiamo regolarmente insetti:
li mangiamo sotto forma
di moscerini, o larve
che sono finite nei succhi di frutta,
nelle salse, nei sughi.
Li mangiamo sotto forma di tarme,
che sono finite nella pasta o nel pane;
e mangia insetti chi utilizza il rossetto.
Pare infatti che, in un anno,
ciascuno di noi mangi
circa mezzo chilo di insetti.
Ora, detta così sembra un sacchettino:
in realtà, se voi lo moltiplicate
per tutte le persone
che ci sono in Italia,
anche solo in Italia,
arriviamo a circa 35.000 tonnellate.
Dove li mettiamo, tutti 'sti insetti?
Me lo sto chiedendo
da due giorni, in realtà.
Sicuramente, il modo
più gradevole di gustarli
è bevendo un Negroni o uno spritz,
perché - alcuni lo sanno, ma molti no -
in realtà il colore rosso, in molti casi,
è dato da delle cocciniglie,
che producono lo stesso colorante
dei rossetti di cui ho parlato prima.
Per la cronaca, il colorante
si chiama "E120".
Del resto, in gran parte del pianeta
si mangiano regolarmente insetti.
Chi di voi ha trascorso qualche vacanza,
nei mercatini asiatici, sicuramente lo sa.
E quindi, sappiamo che per lo meno
certe specie non fanno male.
Poi, che siano buoni o meno
questo chiaramente dipende
dai gusti personali
e da tutta una serie
di pregiudizi culturali.
Per cui, però, diamo per accettato
che gli insetti si possano mangiare.
Il punto è capire se abbiamo bisogno
di mangiarli oggi, in Occidente,
a dispetto delle nostre tradizioni.
Vi dico subito che la mia risposta è sì,
e per motivi che non c'entrano nulla
con i gusti alimentari miei o vostri.
Dico sì perché oggi in Europa,
e più in generale nel mondo
cosiddetto sviluppato,
utilizzare gli insetti
come cibo per animali,
piuttosto che come alimento per umani,
fa sicuramente bene.
Fa bene all'ambiente,
alle persone, all'economia;
e lo fa per tre ragioni fondamentali.
In primo luogo, per via dell'aumento
della popolazione del pianeta:
oggi, peraltro, è un giorno importante
perché tra oggi e domani, secondo l'ONU,
dovremmo raggiungere
gli otto miliardi di abitanti.
Entro il 2050, saremo circa 10 miliardi.
E sono miliardi di persone
che ovviamente vorranno mangiare,
mangiare cibi sempre più nutrienti
e sempre più a base di carne.
Peccato che non ci siano
alimenti per tutti;
e, soprattutto,
non possiamo negare ad altri
il diritto alla buona alimentazione
che noi, in qualche modo,
pretendiamo per noi stessi.
Quindi, che ci piaccia o meno,
dobbiamo trovare dei sistemi
di produzione alternativi,
o perlomeno più efficienti.
Il secondo motivo è proprio legato
ai sistemi di produzione alimentare,
soprattutto per quanto riguarda
la produzione di mangimi.
Quello dei mangimi è un mercato immenso:
tenete conto che nel mondo, ogni anno,
70.000.000.000 di animali di allevamento
finiscono sulle nostre tavole.
E a questi animali dobbiamo aggiungere
i pesci e gli animali allevati
per produrre uova o latte.
Tutti questi animali
vengono alimentati con materie prime -
cioè il grano, il mais,
la soia, la farina di pesce -
che hanno attraversato
effettivamente mezzo mondo
per arrivare sulle nostre tavole.
L'Europa importa l'80% delle componenti
che servono per fare mangimi.
Gli insetti possono ridurre
le importazioni di questi materiali,
soprattutto la farina di pesce;
e li possono sostituire, in parte.
E in più aggiungono elementi nutritivi
di qualità, di ottima qualità,
per le diete degli animali stessi.
In pratica, possono essere cibo
per il nostro cibo.
Infine dobbiamo considerare,
in questo elenco
di consumatori di mangimi,
gli animali domestici,
che sono circa 200 milioni in Europa
e la cui alimentazione
è uno dei principali business
delle grandi aziende multinazionali,
che sull'alimentazione degli animali
producono prodotti e fatturati.
Pensate a cosa comprate
per il vostro cane, o il vostro gatto,
e poi fatevi i conti.
Terzo motivo a favore
dell'impiego degli insetti
è legato a quello che, per me,
è il vero scandalo
di quello di cui stiamo parlando:
lo scandalo dello spreco alimentare.
Un terzo degli alimenti prodotti
viene, letteralmente, gettato via
lungo tutte le fasi di produzione,
trasformazione, vendita e consumo.
Parliamo di un terzo -
stiamo parlando di circa 1.000.000.000
di tonnellate all'anno, secondo la FAO.
Peraltro, questo spreco
è quasi tutto concentrato
nella nostra parte di mondo:
quella grassa, sempre a dieta.
Sprecare, ovviamente, non piace a nessuno.
Però, dobbiamo essere consapevoli
che oggi non ci sono molte soluzioni
per gestire lo scarto,
il rifiuto organico.
Sostanzialmente sono due:
la produzione di compost,
più o meno di qualità;
e la valorizzazione energetica
con produzione di biogas o biometano.
Ricordo che queste
sono soluzioni che paghiamo noi,
con le nostre tasse interamente.
E vanno benissimo,
ovviamente vanno benissimo
nel momento in cui non ci siano
delle soluzioni più virtuose,
quindi più economiche,
o più efficienti o meno costose
come ad esempio il recupero
per produrre materiali,
per produrre alimenti per gli animali.
Ora, questo elenco di priorità che vedete
non l'ho inventato io:
è proprio previsto
dalle normative comunitarie.
E se ci fate caso, è anche un criterio
assolutamente di buon senso.
Per cui, la situazione è questa:
in un pianeta dove almeno
tre miliardi di persone
fanno fatica a mangiare,
non hanno un'alimentazione
costante e adeguata,
ci sono quantità immense di prodotti
che fanno il giro del mondo
per essere utilizzate
in un sistema alimentare
dove si mangia troppo e si spreca di più.
Non è bello: lo capite da soli,
ci arriviamo tutti.
È ingiusto: un sistema squilibrato,
un sistema insostenibile.
E ovviamente, dovremmo fare qualcosa.
Cambiare gli stili di vita
è una soluzione:
ma è già difficile, per ciascuno di noi,
pensare alla propria dieta:
pensate imporre stili di vita, o modelli,
a popolazioni immense,
a masse di popolazioni:
diventa un obiettivo demagogico.
Per cui, io vi propongo
di spingere il vostro sguardo
oltre la situazione odierna.
Pensate che lo scarto alimentare
non sia più un problema,
che ci sia un modo più sostenibile
per produrre proteine
e che dai rifiuti si possano produrre
nuovi materiali e nuovi prodotti.
Non è utopia, eh:
è un obiettivo che già adesso, in parte,
si può raggiungere grazie agli insetti.
Questo perché molti insetti
si possono allevare
dando loro da mangiare quelli che sono
scarti alimentari, residui, sottoprodotti,
che altrimenti verrebbero buttati via.
E producono proteine
e componenti alimentari di qualità,
la cui produzione è molto,
molto più efficiente
di qualsiasi altra filiera alimentare.
Anche in termini ambientali:
in questo schema potete vedere
quanto sia minore l'impronta ecologica
della produzione di carne di insetto
rispetto ad altre filiere:
quella del manzo, degli ovini,
dei polli e dei suini.
Sia per quanto riguarda la CO2,
sia per quanto riguarda
il consumo delle risorse,
e dell'impronta idrica.
Ora, se voi, secondo
questa chiave di lettura -
per tornare alla domanda
che ponevo all'inizio -
il nostro bisogno di insetti
risponde ad una problematica
che non c'entra assolutamente nulla
con la difesa delle tradizioni culinarie,
o con la bontà delle produzioni alimentari
di cui - in Italia, soprattutto -
andiamo giustamente fieri.
Al limite, l'impiego
nei mangimi degli insetti
aiuta ad arricchire gli standard
di eccellenza dei prodotti,
perché aggiunge a delle qualità innegabili
il valore della sostenibilità,
e della responsabilità ambientale,
delle imprese che li producono.
Per questi motivi tutti -
in Europa, da qualche anno,
ha cominciato a svilupparsi
una nuova industria.
Un'industria che utilizza gli insetti
per bioconvertire gli scarti organici
in farine e grassi alimentari.
Sono materiali che poi,
in gran parte, diventano mangimi -
mangimi per polli, pesci,
suini e animali domestici -
e che iniziano anche a essere utilizzati
per produrre componenti
alimentari per l'uomo.
Ad oggi, in Europa saremo una quarantina
di aziende, in questo settore;
però, nei prossimi anni,
saremo sicuramente di più.
Alcuni player europei,
soprattutto nel Nord Europa,
stanno realizzando grandi impianti
in cui allevano
enormi quantità di insetti,
all'interno di stabilimenti
di un unico stabilimento produttivo.
Che è un approccio che va bene
in certi contesti industriali,
sicuramente;
però, noi abbiamo scelto
un modello diverso,
un modello che si basa su due fattori:
un modello di sharing economy evoluta -
poi vi spiegherò cosa intendo -
e l'allevamento di questa mosca.
Questa mosca è un insetto
a me molto simpatico:
nessuno si accorge che esiste,
per cui non dà fastidio
come l'altra mosca,
quella che ovviamente
ci disturba quotidianamente.
Si chiama Hermetia Illucens,
oppure Mosca soldato.
Ha come unico obiettivo,
durante la sua vita larvale,
di mangiare grandi quantitativi
di materiale in decomposizione.
Poi, una volta sfarfallata,
e diventata adulta,
si preoccupa unicamente di riprodursi.
Da adulta non mangia, non sciama:
se ne sta isolata, e lontana dagli uomini,
ad aspettare di trovare un partner,
dopo di che si accoppia e muore,
come spesso capita, tra gli insetti.
È l'insetto edibile, cioè commestibile,
più allevato del mondo
a livello industriale:
è un simbolo di quella che sarà
una realtà dirompente
nei prossimi decenni,
in grado di rivoluzionare
il concetto stesso di scarto,
di rifiuto organico
e di sostenibilità
delle filiere alimentari.
Noi abbiamo deciso
di allevare questa mosca
sulla base di una visione,
che è pensare alla realtà
agricola europea:
quindi, non grandi
stabilimenti centralizzati
ma una rete diffusa
di piccoli centri di bioconversione
presso le aziende agricole.
A questi allevamenti
abbiamo dato il nome di "Bugs Farm",
e cioè "Fattoria degli insetti".
Nell'immagine potete vedere un particolare
di quelle che sono le camere
di bio conversione, cioè di allevamento,
in cui le larve crescono
alimentandosi con gli scarti organici.
La nostra non è una modalità
di recupero degli scarti
alternativa al biogas, o al biometano:
no, assolutamente;
in realtà, è complementare.
Questo perché in campo agricolo
riusciamo a legarci
a queste realtà agricole importanti,
valorizzando quelli che, ad esempio,
sono i cascami termici,
o le produzioni in eccesso
di energia, sempre termica,
che non sono in grado
di essere utilizzate.
Quando parlavo di sharing economy, però,
parlavo del fatto
che noi stiamo proponendo la creazione
di un network sociale, e produttivo,
tra diversi operatori.
Che sono operatori che collaborano
per lo sviluppo di un obiettivo comune,
in cui mettiamo insieme:
le industrie alimentari
che hanno degli scarti da smaltire;
inseriamo una serie di operatori
per la raccolta e la trasformazione
di questi materiali;
le imprese agricole,
che devono bioconvertire
gli scarti nelle bugs farm;
e poi, alla fine i clienti dei prodotti
derivati dalla bioconversione.
Che sono tendenzialmente mangimifici,
imprese agricole e imprese chimiche.
Perché non ve l'ho detto,
ma dagli insetti si ricavano
anche produzioni agricole,
componenti fertilizzanti,
decisamente importanti.
Finora, ho parlato di quello
che potremmo definire il mio business.
Però, permettetemi ora di parlare
di quelli che io ritengo essere
i veri artefici del successo
delle startup come le nostre,
cioè il capitale umano.
Questa è la squadra di collaboratori
con cui mi confronto tutti i giorni:
notate la mia età, notate la loro.
Gran parte dell'avventura mia,
e dei miei soci,
è motivata da ragazzi e ragazze
che hanno un alto livello
di scolarizzazione:
sono laureati in agraria;
in tecnologie alimentari;
sono entomologi;
laureati in chimica.
Sono giovani donne, e giovani uomini
che hanno preparazione,
passione e molta volontà
di sviluppare innovazione
e ricerca in questo campo.
Sono per me dei veri talenti,
hanno un'età media
al di sotto dei 30 anni,
e nei prossimi mesi,
questo organico crescerà ancora.
Io trovo affascinante che,
dopo tanti anni passati a fare ricerche
su come allontanare
gli insetti dal nostro mondo,
come difendersi dagli insetti,
ci sia finalmente
una generazione di scienziati
che studia e cerca di promuovere
l'armonia ambientale
considerando gli insetti
come alleati dell'uomo.
È un campo di lavoro
nuovissimo, entusiasmante,
in cui coesistono:
imprese specializzate,
università, centri di ricerca;
e molti ricercatori
di valore, come i nostri.
Ora, vi ho parlato di insetti
e di economia circolare:
ma non fermiamoci qui.
Come mi ricorda sempre
una mia collaboratrice,
di quelle che ho presentato prima,
dobbiamo proporci di superare
la logica del singolo progetto.
Noi dobbiamo superare l'idea
delle "nuove proteine",
e puntare, nel tempo,
a una visione più ampia di biofabbrica.
Per realizzare, anche grazie
a quelle che possono essere
le implementazioni dovute
allo sviluppo genetico:
lotta biologica,
produzione di nuovi materiali,
bioplastiche,
elementi chimici e medicinali.
Ora è possibile, e non è
un futuro remoto: è oggi.
Concludo: gli insetti fanno già parte
dell'alimentazione di almeno
un terzo dell'umanità;
possono trasformare il 100%
dei rifiuti organici
in prodotti a valore aggiunto;
aggiungono qualità nutrizionali,
e valore, alle filiere alimentari.
Per cui, capite, la questione non è
se mangeremo gli insetti o come,
cioè se li mangeremo in modo diretto,
con delle ricette particolari,
o come componente
di qualche cibo industriale,
oppure se li mangeremo
perché saranno finiti, in qualche modo,
nello stomaco del galletto
di qualità certificata,
e di produzione locale,
che serviamo sulle nostre tavole.
La questione è capire, e accettare,
il fatto che gli insetti saranno
degli alleati importanti
per uno sviluppo sostenibile,
per un modello di economia
veramente circolare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)